hi this is pressure Locker in this video
we're going to evaluate whether a common
way of choosing the dealer and poker is
actually a fair system imagine we have a
poker game between four players one two
three and four
we'll deal out cards from the deck until
we see the first ace this person will be
the dealer this is a system of dealing
to the first ace but is this a fair
system let's do an experiment to find
out we'll deal out the cards and see who
gets the first ace and then we'll put a
counter next to that player we'll repeat
this experiment a hundred times and keep
track of which player was designated the
dealer using the system of dealing to
the first ace as you can tell from the
preliminary results player four gets the
first ace very few times and the earlier
players are much more favored as we do
this experiment a hundred times we see
this pattern holds true and in the end
we're going to collect the data and
analyze it if dealing to the first days
were a fair system we would expect a
uniform distribution what we found was
big variance between the players in
particular the earlier players were much
more likely to get the first ace this is
in line with the theoretical results
dealing to the first ace is not a fair
system if you want a truly fair way of
picking the dealer you can either do a
high card you can draw straws or you can
do random numbers which is what most
tournaments do please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can support mind your
decisions on patreon to get exclusive
rewards you can also catch me on my blog
minor decisions on Twitter at pressure
Locker or get my books at Amazon